olá tudo isso o que faltou foi quem
falou em andar que sejam muito bem
vindos
aí o estrago de que um vídeo muito
especial e não sei se gosto pessoal que
não está tudo bem comigo tudo bem comigo
o dark joy sofrem a fibra ótica com o
lado pessoal de quem fala é o dark seja
muito bem-vindo jamais o viu o estrago
de que mais um vídeo é eleita que o
cheiro que vinha tudo tudo tudo e mais
alguma coisa toda é mais uma vez de ver
os nossos comentários e tem lapsos
imagens benefícios naked sadia
o maruim mais sangue mas estou sentindo
no bolso de rock gótico
olha só como é mal estendeu parece me
sinto pai por aí uns imagem viva em
portugal não sai de manhã em portugal
não é o seu personagem é real sim o seu
personagem é tomado pelo futebol não
imaginava mas se jogar na bola porque
ela bota bem grande seu personagem é uma
mulher não o seu personagem vive da
música sim o seu personagem é
considerado ídolo do seu time time que
tem o seu personagem já morreu ou não
esse é um detalhe e personagem canta
músicas românticas podem então nós vamos
ter aí eu acho que é melhor não teremos
música romântica animadas coisas né
seu personagem é dj dizem que seu
personagem sheila mala
quem compõe músicas sim o seu personagem
tem uma banda toca em uma banda de rock
sim o personagem tem a voz principal do
grupo sim o seu estágio uso maquiagem
pesada pessoal mas não só estou a usar
maquiagem pesada
o seu personagem e gótico [ __ ] vai
ganhar sim
a nossa aqui na inter acertou mais uma
vez pessoal eu quero personagem difícil
está corra dentro encontraram uma bolsa
camargo tenta encontrar poeira cósmica
o enredo é custo
fomos próxima personagem acho o sporting
do mortal kombat plantão
tenho lá o seu personagem é uma mulher
por quem o faça assim sempre agora
nenhum personagem é cantor não se
restringem essa música no futebol quando
as gestões do mundo agora eu jogo
futebol em portugal somos campeões
[ __ ] que um seu personagem vive em
portugal não se personagem é real não o
seu personagem é um homem do dancing o
seu personagem é de um jogo sem o seu
personagem sabe dirigir será que só acho
que não só eu mas a gente tem que ver um
sim o seu personagem luta usando uma
espada sim o seu personagem é magrelo
não só personagem tem memória
fotográfica fotográfica é o seu
personagem tem barba
sim o seu estágio é um deus uma deusa
não o seu personagem é um marinheiro o
pirata não o seu personagem já foi rei
também não [ __ ] seu personagem usa
facas sim às vezes o seu personagem
italiano ou não pois o seu personagem
tem poderemos sim o aquele erro é ro
eu tenho pressa tenho já a gestmin
dirigentes procuram o meu canal não uso
por isso o vídeo que o encontro
sinto muito tensa
quem achar em londrina joyce e pra quem
não sabe a menina joyce aquela youtube
supostamente está sequestrado e tal mas
vamos tentar encontrá lo agora o seu
personagem é um desenho animado
o estágio é o desanimado não o seu
personagem ora no seu país não o seu
personagem usa roupas masculinas não o
seu estágio é uma mulher cim do seu
personagem faz parte de uma série de tv
não só personagem é cantor também não o
seu estágio já fiz algum filme não só a
história que ela já o seu personagem é
um youtube wedding o seu personagem é
brasileiro não o seu personagem é lula
sim é loira sim o seu personagem gosta
de chuva que eu não sei quem ele nao
britânico para corrigir calma corrigir
britânico sim
marina só pessoal é marina jorge estava
em ela foi encontrada eu encontrar e
posso garantir que ela é mesmo esta esta
sombra ela mesmo ela como quem dava como
meu eu tava do s3 a do meu estado super
preocupado com ela eu sou agora a sério
a marina joyce é um caso que tal agora
achar a internet supostamente é uma em
outubro
youtube agora ter tido um golpe
agora muitos inscritos por que elas
possam estar sendo sequestrada só ajudem
por favor não come pessoa precisa mesmo
da nossa ajuda importante pra junina ou
julina